[Music]
nova was an innovation schools for
middle and high school students instead
of having your long classes like math or
english or something we have two
week-long studios and so in these
studios these are projects where we're
presented with an open-ended problem and
almost every project is created with a
team which makes it so much more fun our
pedagogy is based on an architectural
model that is really about a design
process it's teaching critical thinking
it's teaching the ability to empower
your own ideas and go through an
iterative creative process that is
collaborative that it has a critical
loop to it the first couple days we do a
lot of introductory work where the
students get to learn deeply about the
problems that we're addressing and then
we do a lot of brainstorming and
ideation after that phase after the
students divide up into groups I'll go
around to different groups and help them
both by giving feedback about their
designs and their ideas but also
actually helping them technically so
when I was at regular school there was
no chance for me to be myself really
what's really great about newbie is it's
all like what I want to do I'm very
passionate about my projects I'm working
on and I get very interested in them
it's very open and independent and well
most people would think that's a bad
thing kids could just do whatever they
want you're really giving a task here
that it's great when you you're into the
task you really want to just get it done
I came to new because I I like building
things
that the new will be a best fit for me
for building my ideas like making them
come to life and I love regular school
but I thought you'd be very calm really
interested in the engineering and
designing aspect of building and
prototyping and stuff and all this cool
software work so right now I'm working
on a hand drive wheelchair attachment
and so what it does is it uses a
ratcheting mechanism which means it has
free resistance in one direction and
blocks in the other direction but what
we've done is we've stacked two on top
of each other so when you switch the
handle it actually goes backwards I mean
a super cool thing about this which was
like crazy to make was that this one is
actually has a gearing up ratio so it's
faster than width if you would just push
the wheel one to one so this is a one
for the projects that I recently created
which is a music box
that attaches to a bus so the the need
for it is that when you when you sit in
a bus stop obviously everyone's on their
phones and in the winter it's cold and
there's really nothing to do while
waiting for it so the purpose of this
was to create an interactive piece of
art that that brings people together in
a communal way so this is a bus Pole
that everyone sees at the bus stop and
what we created was a cylindrical music
box that attaches to it this is the
music box part there's a resonation
system down here so these are the actual
tongs that are at any given point we
just want to track where the students
are in their process we track the
creative skills and mostly for us this
revolves around Canada critique process
how the students are kind of taking that
critique and synthesizing it into design
decisions how they are communicating
their ideas and how they are
collaborating with others
I think the critique process is
something that is definitely an
adjustment period for some kids and I
think part of it is that like when
you're a creative person when you have
creative ideas it's really hard to
separate them from yourself and so it's
very common for students yet defensive
or to just kind of write off the
critiques just because it's so hard to
like really put yourself out there
and I've definitely had critiques that
have gone really well and I've also had
critiques where like my eyes water a
little bit but I'm also you know I know
that these people are here to help me
like these people are my family at any
of you our hope is that a student goes
away from this experience with the idea
that what they believe in and what they
think matters and that it's really about
the process not about the thing that
comes out the other end I think the most
important piece is really creating
learning environments that engage the
students and you don't engage the
students by giving them problems that
you already know the answer for you know
you engage them by giving problems that
they are excited about that they feel
that they could change the world by
solving them
[Music]
you